[Music]
hey everybody its charlie everybody was
freaking out about a new Avengers 4
teaser that the Russos were trolling
everyone with earlier this week so I'll
explain what's going on with that even
the co-president of Marvel Studios was
getting in on the fun Louie Esposito is
one of the most powerful people at
Marvel because I'm looking hard but I
can't figure out what's in the photo and
the Russo brothers won't tell me of
course he knows what's going on day to
day they're watching the dailies like
everyone else
so we'll break it down no worries
there's a new round of that spider-man
ps4 giveaway all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on the video I'll name a new winner at
the end of this there's a couple things
that are going on here there's a couple
objects in frame as well as the way that
they framed the photo for some pattern
analysis to sort of tease because the
next big thing that's gonna happen is is
they'll announce with the official title
for Avengers 4 is so of course they're
having a little bit of fun with people
like just posting random stuff although
not necessarily as random as you think
just saying what do you think is going
on here just making people go crazy
driving up a whole bunch of hype and
awareness for what's going on it is a
diabolically perfect marketing technique
but there actually is some stuff
happening it's not totally trolling so
people have gotten crazy with the memes
and pattern analysis seeing all kinds of
letters spelled out by the shapes in the
frame here but on a more basic level you
have Russo brother sitting in between
two ladders that just form a z' which is
why I think the most likely title of
that they're teasing here is Avengers
Assemble but it's not the only title
that you can pick out here because in
reality if you stretch it just a little
bit more there are four A's there's two
more shapes on both sides of these
ladders so for A's Avengers for haha
also a wonderful coincidence but
Avengers Assemble even though it's the
most practical title isn't my only guess
so even though eternity is a really big
concept in the Eternals movie was
announced this morning they just hired a
director they have some writers meaning
that they're gonna be releasing that
sometime in the next two years all signs
are pointing towards them invoking some
concept of the Eternals within Avengers
4 even if they're not a big part of the
plot because there's too much stuff that
they have to pay off from infinity war
so don't expect a ton of brand-new stuff
to get thrown into the mix like they're
trying to wrap up Oh
bunch of phase-one Avengers arts so that
I can be throwing too much at you beyond
what it takes to close that down but yes
I do think that Avengers eternity is a
good title guess there are a couple
titles that people still think like
endgame that were thrown out a while ago
worthy Avengers we can bust arms dealers
all the live long day but that up there
that's that's a game
[Music]
so first thing the Russo said that the
title of Avengers 4 was never said by
anyone in any of the dialogue during
infinity war in dr. strange said the
words endgame so that automatically
disqualifies endgame as a potential
title so not too long ago when infinity
war came out in theatres and people were
hounding Kevin Feige to explain theories
about the title for Avengers 4 he got
pretty real with everyone and said look
we kind of regret making this as big of
a deal as we did with all the secrecy
because it's gotten way overhyped it's
gonna feel underwhelming when we reveal
what it actually is they said that they
actually came up with the name for
Avengers 4 really early in the writing
process when they were breaking both
infinity war and Avengers 4 so that
implies it's a very simple idea that's a
big call back to the core of what the
Avengers are all about and what is their
big catchphrase that harkens back to one
of the greatest moments in their
cinematic history Avengers Assemble with
this scene from the first Avengers movie
so right now that is why that is my
number one theory about the title but
obviously it could still be a couple of
other things so you just need to keep an
open mind just remember with the Russos
what Kevin Feige have said it is not as
complicated as people are making it out
to be it's getting overhyped
it's gonna be relatively simple it has
four other theories with end in the
title I don't think that they want to
put a blanket on any of this they want
to get people excited for more Avengers
like the Russo said that Avengers
Forever is the closest that people have
come to guessing the title even though
that itself is not the title so think
about it this way Disney wants a really
clicky title that'll get people really
excited to keep coming back to Avengers
films even after some of these phase 1
Avengers aren't around anymore expect
the Russos to keep trolling people for
the next couple of months until they've
revealed the title and because we got
the Captain Marvel trailer wait earlier
than I expected I also would not be
surprised if they revealed the title
relatively soon but the other thing
that's going on in this photo when he
says look closely is that there's
actually a device that showed up during
infinity war inside the New Avengers
base over on the left side of the frame
here there's this piece of technology
that looks a little bit like
reactor or a piece of a weapon people
think that it might be war machines
proton cannon or Iron Man's proton
cannon from the comics it debuted during
Iron Man 2 94 when he was using his
telepresence armor and it's just like a
really really big gun that attaches to
him so obviously a war machine is the
person with the big guns on the Avengers
movies so he would be the one to use
something like that but just because
this showed up in the background of a
shop with war machine doesn't confirm
that it is the proton cannon it looks
like it's just something that Tony has
been working on it could be a reactor
that they used to harness quantum energy
but also the fact that it's sitting here
kind of confirms that this behind the
stage area where the russo is just
chilling out in between scenes is on the
set of this new avengers facility where
they're filming a scene if you're not an
actor or you haven't been in the
performing arts or anything like that
the tape on the ground those marks are
to let actors know where they're
supposed to stand in scenes but I think
the reason why the photo is black and
white is one to sort of set the mood
into so that you don't know which actors
marks those are because they use
different colors to denote different
actors like when you have a bunch of
people on set you just give an actor a
color so you put down say like red tape
for Robert Downey jr. so you have a
bunch of red marks all over the place so
when it comes time to film scenes RDJ
knows where all of his marks are and
different actors don't get confused
because they have different colors so
how do you keep people from knowing who
is in a scene you just make the photo
black and white so you can't tell the
different colors of all the marks at
first we're going to Atlanta for some
Avengers
it's gonna be fun I already talked a
little bit about the Eternals
announcement this morning it's gonna
take them you know good two years to
turn that movie around but they have two
riders in a director now meaning that
eventually they'll start casting they'll
start beating the story out there was a
Marvel movie that was rumored to be
shooting at Pinewood Studios next year
we thought that it was going to be
Doctor Strange - it could actually be
that Eternals movie instead they have a
bunch of studio space booked they were
originally going to be shooting
guardians of the galaxy 3 maybe they've
fast-tracked the Eternals movie and that
will take guardians place in the release
schedule spring 2020 so it's still long
ways off we'll get more details about
that a little while the other really
cool thing that just happened this week
is that the Disney CEO did a big
teleconference talking about a whole
bunch of stuff within that he explained
what's gonna happen with the x-men and
with the future of Kevin Feige at Disney
and Marvel Studios so one just breathe a
sigh of relief Kevin Feige is confirmed
to be staying at Marvel Studios for the
foreseeable future - the more important
thing I think is the fact that he is
also going to control all of the x-men
IP from Fox when they get it you
probably had already assumed this even
if you hadn't done it out loud it just
makes sense that if they get those
characters they'll just tell Kevin Feige
make whatever movie you want to now
there are no restrictions there you know
maybe a couple problems with making a
whole movie but beyond that in the Sony
spider-man sharing arrangement you have
control of pretty much any character
within the Marvel comic book universe
just do whatever you feel like doing so
everybody freaked out in the comments
let me know what you think about all
this and what you think the Russos are
teasing is the title in this photo here
what will happen is is there still a
whole bunch of comic book news that drop
I'll try to get through all that footage
and everything as fast as possible leave
your requests in the comments below and
TV 521 congratulations you're the latest
giveaway winner from my last big video
I'll do a new round when I post new
Marvel click here for a whole bunch of
new venom footage and click here to
rewatch that Captain Marvel trailer a
billion more times thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you
tonight
[Music]